hi in this video talk about plasmid and
features as a cloning vector so plasmid
is a extra chromosomal DNA other than
the bacterial chromosome we generally
encodes for some antibiotic resistance
and generally as a chemical nature they
are small circular double-stranded DNA
molecule now mostly the plasmids are
present in bacteria however some are key
bacteria also has these plasmids now in
this video we would look at how plasmid
could be a useful tool for genetic
engineering and what are the important
features that make the plasmid as an
important cloning vector so in a copy
machine we give our document and select
the number of copies and we obtain as an
output the number of copies that we want
in genetic engineering sometimes we want
our gene of interest in more copies but
how do we use a copy machine to copy our
DNA so we put in a vector which is
generally a plasmid and put the plasmid
inside a molecular copy machine which is
bacteria and ask the bacteria to copy it
now first of all as the bacteria grows
in optimal growth conditions and
temperature the plasmids which holds the
gene of interest also grows and thus we
have more copies of our gene of interest
now some of the bacterias inherently
maintains a low number of copies of
plasmid and some bacteria has high
number of plasmids so this copy number
of plasmid is a regulated process and if
you want to know more about how a
bacteria can regulate its copy number
then you should watch another video
about plasmid copy number regulation in
the same playlist and the plasmid copy
number regulation is important because
if the plasmid copy number is too high
then it caused a energy
to the bacteria and if it's too low then
there is a risk of losing the plasmid or
losing the antibiotic resistance or
other important gene along with the
plasmid and that could be evolutionary
detrimental for the bacteria now let's
just quickly look at the overall key
features of a cloning vector now idea
including vector vector should has low
molecular weight because first of all if
you have low molecular weight it's easy
to handle it's resistant to shearing and
isolation and transformation into the
bacteria is easy second it should have
selectable and screw noble marker such
that it can be distinguished from the
non recombinant ones and most
importantly it should have a multiple
cloning site which has all sort of large
variety of restriction sites cut the
plasmid and insert our gene of interest
now one of the most important site in
the plasmid is the origin of replication
the origin of replication is the site
where the replication of the plasmid
starts and it's regulated by several
sense and antisense RNAs which I'm not
going to talk about in details however a
plasmid inside the bacteria need to also
replicate right when the bacteria is
growing the plasmids need to be
replicated and segregated just like the
bacterial chromosome so origin of
replication inside a plasmid is very
important apart from the origin of
replication the most important site in
the plasmid is the multiple cloning site
and the multiple cloning site is the
site where you put your gene of interest
and because multiple cloning site has
multiple restriction sites you can cut
it there and cut the gene of interest
with the same restriction enzyme and put
the gene of interest in the multiple
cloning site in the cassette of the
plasmid backbone so multiple cloning
site generally encompasses several
different restriction enzyme some give
rise to Stickney and some river ice to
plantains which we would be talking
later now if we remember the cloning
workflow so first step is restriction
digestion of the vector with specific
friction enzyme that are present in the
multiple cloning site similarly you have
to cut the gene gene of interest with
the same restriction enzyme then the
ligation step comes where you join the
gene of interest with the plasmic
backbone and just just you are inserting
the gene of interest in the plasmid
backbone then you transform the plasmid
into the bacteria and ask the bacteria
to grow it in number grow the gene of
interest in number now as the bacteria
grows in the Culture Media the number of
the gene is increased so simple right
actually not so here is a problem in the
culture there are some bacteria which
would eat up the plasmid when we are
transforming it but there are some
bacteria which won't take the plasmid
now at the end of the amplification
process of the bacterial growth curve
how would you understand that which
bacteria has taken out the plasmid and
which bacteria has not so you need a
distinguishable marker right so that's
why selectable markers come into the
picture in case of selectable marker it
selects the bacteria again some
selection pressure and most of the cases
the selectable marker are antibiotic
resistance gene encoded by the plasmid
simply if we put antibiotic in the
bacterial culture media it should die
the bacteria should die and should not
grow right normal bacterias only back
those bacterias which have the
antibiotic resistance gene against those
antibiotic that we have added would grow
in that media so in the plasmid if we
have the antibiotic resistance gene then
it would survive and the plus and under
in the bacteria which doesn't have the
antibiotic resistance gene it would die
thereby we can get rid of those
bacterias which have not taken up the
plasmid but the problem is of twofold
here is a second one the second one is
even if the plus means we have digested
we have ligated but some of the plasmid
could get self ligated and not have the
restriction not have the gene of
interest it is just a self ligation
plasmid now how do we do
in between these two variety whether the
bacteria has taken up the plasmid with
gene of interest or it has only taken up
the self ligated plasmid in order to
understand that we need screening
markers mostly in multiple cloning sites
there are certain genes which works like
screening markers one such example is
Lac Z now we all know Lac C is a
component of the lac operon which codes
for p regulatory risk and pitting
electricity's can convert egg CL a
colored product a variant of lactose and
that kind of converts egg scale to a
colored product now if the bacteria is
transformed with the plasmid having the
lag C as a selectable marker gene then
the bacterial colony would be blue in
color because this be like electricity's
is active and they have converted the
colony into a blue color right now
somehow if you insert the gene in a
manner that does that V gene is
disrupted so beta galactosidase
production is gone and you don't have
any color formation so now if you
transform this plasmid and try to plot
it in a petri dish you would have
colonies which are all white in color or
colorless so in that we can clearly
understand the blue colonies correspond
to the self ligating plasmid or
undisrupted screen able marker gene and
the white colonies correspond to the
disrupted screen oval marker gene where
we understand in those colonies the
marker gene is disrupted by our gene of
interest so those white colonies are of
our interest so this is how using we can
using a selectable mark-ass crinimal
marker we can screen for recombinant
colonies right now once we understand
the recombinant colonies are the white
ones we can script this them out and
grow them in bulk cultures and later
that
for further downstream processes which
we would be talking in this whole video
scene so let's just get a summary of
what we learned so far to be learned
that the plasmid has a origin of
replication which allow it to replicate
inside the bacteria individually and it
has multiple zoning sites having 17
cutting sites or several restriction
sites which we can use to cut an insert
or not interest it has a selectable
marker which still next again those
bacteria it has not taken up the plasmid
versus those bacteria which has taken up
at work me I'm a select screen able
marker which can distinguish versus a
recombinant versus an on recombinant
plus right so in this video we get an
overview of it logic in subsequent video
we're getting the details of these
features and how it could be useful for
a molecular biologist to clone certain
look at different type of watching this
video if you have specific questions